the social credit score thing is
interesting don't you think we have our
own forms of that yeah like isn't that
what social media is to a degree
somebody has a blue check and all of a
sudden they're more important their dm's
get open quicker that might be a clout
score but yeah
is currency here then that is cloud
can't get you a mortgage so the big
difference would be how can it not um
they're going to look at documents and
financial statements well it won't
prevent you from getting more if you
have a lot of money but cloud can get
you money and money can get you a
mortgage yes but in in in in a way that
like is i think okay right like the idea
of like clout making you money is fine
like a social credit score in china
can't get you a mortgage but they can
deny you a mortgage absolutely they can
deny you one so they can't get you one
of you
lack of blue check doesn't prevent you
from getting a car loan that's the
difference
right now that's the meaningful what i
would say is that
if you potentially had a blue check or
clout in other areas you could have
access to money and then get that yeah
but see that so that's reverse
engineering that's okay i don't have a
problem with that right that's fine it's
the other side it's if we say you can't
have this yeah i don't have a problem
with can
can is great whatever you can use to
your benefit to get whatever you're
gonna get yeah if it's ethical and legal
and you're not hurting anyone else yeah
fine it's when governments prevent you
from doing certain things because of
maybe your online activity the things
you've said or believe right that is the
social credit score idea that's what i
have an issue and you think we're headed
toward that yes yeah i think so because
i think that
the the population and you saw it with
covet how easy was it to get people to
rat on each other 1200 bucks how easy
was it to get people to call the cops on
14 year old kids skateboarding up the
block how easy was it as long as
someone's convinced they're doing the
morally right thing they will absolutely
become a nazi they don't care and i'm
not saying they were the equivalent to
the nazis but yeah but isn't that
absolutely
dime on each other if they feel like
it's for the purposes of altruism like
they're they're in the right i don't
know if they do it for the purpose of
altruism i think that these are people
who are more or less powerless and then
we gave them a little power and then we
allowed them to be virtuous with that
people were not powerless some of these
people were multi-millionaires hollywood
celebrities so they weren't really
powerless i'm talking about the lady
that comes up to the street and goes put
your mask over your nose sure right like
these people have no power they have no
control in their lives and all of a
sudden someone gave them a big [ __ ]
stick right and they could walk around
saving the world and saving the world is
just enough to get them over the
monumental inconvenience that they're
putting on another [ __ ] human being
so that's what the social credit score
would be i think it would be giving
everyone the ability to save the world
all the time and we if if if it is
parallel thinking yeah we would
immediately fall victim to it sure
because we've been doing it already you
see it already with yelp you see with
airbnb
uber the ratings we all rate each other
all the time right that's why i was kind
of going with the social media yeah yeah
but exactly with uber it's like we can't
wait to rate you i wonder if just our
system maybe their system is a
reflection of of ours like we just have
the free market create that system i
think that we're constantly
constantly rating constantly looking at
someone's [ __ ] outfit there's a whole
show on e about how shitty somebody
dresses like this social media what's
scary to me is that
in order to compete with china i think
there's a there's an element of the us
ruling class that believes we should
become china in order to
if we don't want them exporting all this
technology to the world that's like
surveillance technology in nature
um so what we want to do is we want to
master the automation in the ai so that
we export it to the world and what
scares me about that is that essentially
we're then adopting more kind of
you know kind of more
draconian totalitarian type of policies
that you see in china that you may
start seeing here which i wouldn't love
you know what's funny is you tell me
that we're going to become china i'm
like get the [ __ ] out of here but if you
want to tell me robots are going to kill
us all i'm like yeah 15 years
so who am i to judge do you know what i
mean yeah yeah i don't know it's weird
about becoming china
because it feels like something more
closed society becoming more of like a
society where
you are not as free as you are now hmm
that's
that's what could happen and this is
where i
don't get into conspiracy theories not
that i'm like
too good for it or whatever i'm just
always like but they just seem so far
off from hey we're calling the cops on
kids skateboarding to you know draconian
[ __ ]
city well i mean i don't know how far
off it is
i just can't my brain doesn't connect
the dots my brain always hops off board
is like yeah it seems like too many dots
i'm not we're not getting there yeah i
mean there's a lot of there's a few dots
but i mean again if if we told you
you know after 9 11 that you'd have zero
privacy
you know you would you would do the same
thing you go well there's a lot of dots
between this and that but here we are
i mean your email your phone everything
you do
everything is on the grid everything's
traced yeah you know i mean they can get
rid of you social media could just get
rid of you it for whatever reason
i mean
and people are openly advocating for it
you know getting rid of obviously people
may hate alex jones not like alex jones
whatever but it doesn't end with alex
jones now people are talking about joe
rogan and don't get him out of here it's
like this is a problem
in our society that people are going to
use these companies yeah to get rid of
people that they don't like